oh hey I'm Zack
I'm Keith I'm Ned and I'm Eugene we're
gonna tell you how to become a YouTube
star here we go here's how to be a
YouTube star featuring a try guys could
you turn that down yeah the try guys are
huge YouTube stars they have a massive
fan base and millions of people watch
the four personalities well try anything
first they'll tell us why they're online
formula works why do people like to
watch other people try I think you get
to feel what we feel even though you are
not trying you're watching the core idea
of trying things which is where we
started from is just this idea of
exploring things that are familiar to
other people's passions and identities
so I think on that base level there's an
excitement if we are trying something
that you are familiar with we're either
going to learn something that you care
about or experience a struggle that you
know that you haven't been able to
communicate to the world at large but
then I think there's also just a general
interest and excitement of for guys who
are willing to go into things
with an open mind and see what the world
has to offer so what's a YouTube
personality anyways I there are many
types of YouTube personalities but
probably the best are the ones that talk
straight to camera talk about their life
have a huge social meltdown and then
apologize for yeah that's a really big
thing that's this may be the hardest
video I ever have to make I'm just
we found out that our merch that we
released causes people to reject Obama
excuse me while I sip some house sipping
sipping tea there it is okay they're a
couple YouTube archetypes right you've
got the cutie who's just like innocent
bubbly fun hey guys what's going on
you got the prankster you know the old
jokester the guy that just likes to mess
with his friends there are the Guru's
people that you turn to for advice the
ones who feel like they gotta figure it
all out then you have twins
you only have a half of our Hut your
twin is probably our favorite sub-genre
of youtube is the hot twin sub-genre
there's so many just just attractive
twin couplets and I don't understand
where they all come from and how they
all figure out that just YouTube is
where they belong we were in a museum
actually and the category of the exhibit
was audience surrogates so like
literally us were in the museum
yeah the Tri guys were in a museum not
we were walking in a museum you know I
like to go to museums by myself
sometimes you guys do that yeah yeah but
then children stopped me at the Natural
History Museum just so good a lot I was
looking at the bones and they said what
are you doing by yourself one of the
best collection of bones and I didn't
know what to say and I said it's okay to
be alone sometimes and that sounded so
cryptic and you know what see that's how
you become a YouTube star authenticity
which is why I want to tell you about
the try guys new merch that is it to be
a youtuber you have to be able to plug
molnár ability what is it and why is it
important the reason we are vulnerable
in our videos is because it is okay to
be vulnerable in life and I think we
want to demonstrate that that kind of
thing is good it's healthy and it allows
you to be closer to one another when
you're vulnerable around one another I
just helps do you stigmatize this idea
of showing your emotions I think it
stands in stark contrast to what
it's like a typical view of masculinity
where you're supposed to be stoic and
not show any emotions oftentimes tackle
like very difficult personal subjects
and process it by talking about it on
YouTube Wow
being vulnerable I think allows you to
take the mask off and present what is
hopefully a truer version of yourself it
allows you to be raw it allows you to be
in that place in that place of
vulnerability is where you can make
mistakes where you can admit to failures
and that's where growth can occur it's
kind of hard because everything is
voyeuristic now and everything is like
in your face social media sort of
distorted what we think is real so all
sometimes it's really hard to even
interpret or understand if someone is
being completely themselves if you are
giving a hunt of yourself in that moment
then people can smell it especially the
younger generation they know because I
think we're constantly bombarded now by
ideas of authenticity when really it's
just sometimes to sell something it's
not just branding about the anticipating
on t'k and i think that's good for young
kids to remember when they're starting
to to film themselves just because
that's a difficult thing to do when
you're really young what about over
sharing how much of your life should you
keep to yourself I think the four of us
have struggled with what amount of our
full selves we should put out on the
line like I kept the fact that I had a
girlfriend secret from the internet for
two years just because I wanted to have
that corner of my life where I was you
know growing and experiencing something
organically without it being seen under
the microscope of what like people
thought about her and having to subject
that heard of that on one hand we have
this amazing opportunity to share our
lives and to affect people and to to
show our vulnerabilities and things that
we struggle with it may be you're
struggling with two but also you want to
have a part of your life that is private
and separate especially when it comes to
relationships and family but it's
tougher when you know you're famous for
being you I mean for the most part like
you meet me in public I'm pretty much
the same person you see like I'm a meet
it was my little Dumber on-camera you
have to find out for yourself
when you become other people should not
own
your contents they can own your content
but they can't own the content of the
article everyone get a box an actual
physical box write down all your secrets
yeah take out two then bury the box make
a treasure map huh
give it to future generations they're
gonna have the time of their life oh my
god if you discover the treasure map
right now we would all drop everything
and go right oh my god now it's time to
put it all together we had Ned Eugene
Keith and Zac demonstrate the try guys
method of success with two inventions
the spider catcher and the fruit peeler
it's got brushes this is called the
critter catcher my critter catcher nice
nailed it see what the gun does I beat
the critter might open it up oh I like
can you do that right to camera it looks
like an alien space it's smooth like an
old cartoon that would just say bam bam
I don't even want it for bugs I just
want to play with it I'm not a murder
I'll use my plastic tentacles but if he
was wriggling I think you could get out
of this wait did you guys actually kill
bugs or when you see one or I can't kill
what kind of bug any bugs
well you can't kill cockroaches because
then other cockroaches smell it and they
come
flying cockroach in the wild so yeah at
that time I didn't trust hard enough all
right what's next this is the orange
peel professional not to be confused
with the orange peel and the tribal boy
wow this is gonna get juice everywhere
right on the carousel let's step it down
poke it in the top come on burn the tops
is leaning in through that always do it
oh don't go through the thing just
sometimes you gotta push hard no two
buttons there's a one in two - oh good -
[Music]
oh but it was really a professional it
would have known where I was maybe one
will go backwards this would
[Applause]
you keep going take off take off
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
right now your copy over
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my fella fireman our Eugene and that's
how to become famous on youtubes so
anyway we're generally very
unproblematic so we really like to act
like we are until now why this video is
gonna be us becoming problematic or we
could have kids in the docks ahead